NASA thanks for joining us we're along
two weeks into the World Cup do you
think it's been worth it for Qatar after
all the scrutiny the protest
particularly even in Paris where you are
a lot of the time with screenings being
canceled
listen I mean um as Qatari
coming from Qatar from Doha
I'm so proud honestly with my country my
people my leadership doing in in for the
country for the World Cup itself
it's amazing I'm so proud so happy I
mean I cannot be more happy than this
and
of course you know we saw outside
and let's say in Europe some of the
countries let's say
and some of the media
some of the journalists let's say some
of the politicians
and happy politicians who've taken a
stand maybe politicians from countries
that do be trade deals still with Qatar
British sports Minister who wore rainbow
armband but then you've got the British
prime minister saying hats off to Qatar
yeah I mean listen I'm not politician
and I don't want to enter into politics
and I don't understand anything in the
politics and I don't want to understand
but one thing you know the politician if
they want to use the sport to promote
themselves
to do to achieve something in their
agenda they were not success definitely
you know because
sport is sports it's nothing to do with
politics and that's what we're doing
here in Catholic just Sport and football
so all the politicians try to use this
for their own agenda all of them failed
but the Qatar sport is also a means of
projecting power isn't it some of the
Investments that you're overseeing the
World Cup itself listen the sport in
Qatar I believe you know how I see it
myself I was tennis player thanks God
the government invested me as a human
being to be athlete and today I'm here
well I am what I'm doing for my country
so the governments of course invested in
a small dedication Health that's the
most infrastructure so proud of our our
leadership and our country you know I
mean if you can see yesterday was going
from Stadium to stadium and you know
took all the infrastructure that we had
trust me there's not so many and even in
Europe like here in Doha so proud I mean
you know I've been being very humbled
but um I have we have to be proud today
and say it loudly that we are proud of
our country and we've been done
for the World Cup and before the World
Cup you spend a lot of time in Europe
your businesses are in Europe do you
think Europeans do have a right to take
a stand on morality issues and human
rights
if if we want to mix again football with
politics then gonna be a mess
I think people again using it for their
own agenda is not
for
better for the human being and for
people you know I think we are as
Catholic people I think we are good
people trust me and I'm sure of it
because
I know our people we I know our
leadership and they are best people in
the world that can't say it again
proudly and that's not fair what's been
people using and some of the media also
using this against
our people are against Qatar we are not
the best but trust me
we are much better than a lot of people
and much better relation we are as
scattered people
we have this human rights law inside us
as our DNA our culture we don't need any
law to tell us what we do what we don't
do you know and that's what sometimes
hurt me really not saying yeah you know
there's this numbers fake numbers coming
from some of the media about you know
labels and all this stuff it's helped me
so much because my people they are very
good people trust me they are very open
heart and you see it here they're very
friendly you know our religion by the
way don't allowed us to do these things
it's against religion all of us the same
we need to treat you know people exactly
the same that's what more than low it's
religion so I cannot understand all this
you know rumor and media and agenda and
politician using it just for their own
agenda that's I will not let it honestly
first time I'm gonna talk about it
because I had enough of it why are you
looking to sort of sell stakes in Paris
saint-german are you potentially may be
looking to sell the club I will correct
you hear rob you know we're not willing
to sell or we don't ask to sell people
about us so when approach you need to
look at all the opportunity right so
we're looking at the opportunity why not
to have strategic
investor investors at the club fantastic
why not
you've had a lot of friction with Saudi
Arabia the public investment fund has
been linked with potentially buying a
stake in Paris saint-german is that
something you would be willing to accept
listen this is not true absolutely not
soon German
um listen I mean you know things are
that again the religion is better and
that's what we will link but that's what
we want what we want to achieve to have
great relation with everybody you know
we want to have peace with everybody
that's it about that whole leadership
you know policy that you know to have
you know obese with everybody but Saudi
Arabia is still blocking some of the
being signals of the World Cup you go
ask them about the Rope
have you had an answer why well I don't
have an answer you're obviously sort of
paying for the second half of the season
it's hard to get away from things like
the transfer window Cristiano Ronaldo is
now a free agent you have the chance to
be able to unite Cristiano Ronaldo and
Lionel Messi in the same club team for
the first time
Christiano Big Time Legend one of the
best
player ever in the history of football
but I think for us it's really difficult
for the moment you know the three
players that we have is very difficult
but I wish him all the best he's
fantastic and he's still amazing player
obviously you've got Lionel Messi whose
contract runs out at the end of the
season just think you will get to keep
him or is he ready for a new challenge
you know I said this before I'm gonna
keep this here the same thing I'm not
going to change my mind you know we
agreed together to talk after the World
Cup see what's going to happen what you
want to do what we want to do the plan
and all the stuff so we'll talk so
there's no decision from him or from our
side next week we're due to get the
non-biden ruling from The Advocate
General over the super league case we're
going to hear from the European court of
justice next week on the Super League
Kate
are you concerned that they might rule
in favor of the Super League clubs you
know
before to answer this question you know
uh here in paddle playing with all the
legend X players all of them I asked
them all of them against us see also the
fans
presidents managers everybody so this is
to answer your question this is is not a
legal contract a social contract
and I said it before the fans will never
let it happen
clubs will never let it happen whatever
happened in the decision so I'm not
really worried about the decision even
I think you know they will they will
they will vote in in our favor that
against it but if not to not change
anything
how will you fight that though if they
say actually anyone can set up a company
nobody was going to join them nobody
will join them nobody will go to the
stadium fans nobody will organize
anything because in UK there's a law you
cannot do it no example you know the
English Club French German who they
gonna play three of them
fantastic fantastic soberly
there's no law in England though yet to
stop it yeah but you know they I
remember your ex prime minister said
that they will now give Visa they will
not give entrance and all this stuff so
there is really
you know hard push from the government
and it will be for everybody you know
you know the damage will be in whole
football
it's not just a national team and and
youth everything people they don't think
they're just super league and now they
said we're gonna open a little bit
that's just fake I mean just a trick you
know and and we know their attention so
it will never happen do you think you've
definitely killed off the Super League
definitely it's gone
and Juventus seen their entire board go
so I think you know that's thank you for
for your question I think you know I
would love to ask the new management to
join a game that is here to join the
family you know I hope they will be
smarter people there and would love to
to
you know to invite them to come back to
the family that's what we want you know
and I think
you know John Elkin he's very smart very
nice guy I know him and I'm going to
have chat with him I'll talk to him you
know to invite him to to to come and
just forgot this
stupid uh plan you've still got the
Rogue elements you've still got
Barcelona Real Madrid pursuing this
super league but you know my question is
you know by the way we'll respect the
fans The Institute of the clubs but you
know management what they want honestly
I mean you know they're playing
Champions League so why are they playing
Championship they don't want if they
let's leave Champions League go play by
yourself plan your domestic go do a
super cup between three of you what are
you playing the championship if I don't
like something I say I don't like it and
I'm not gonna do it they said yeah the
worst and and and celebrating when they
won which they deserve it by the way I'm
not criticizing you know it's nothing
personal between you know me or them or
you know just
the world of football
you know why I mean I I honestly from
here first time I want to buy them to
come back you know just stop your crazy
idea I mean you know just be back and
let's talk and be part of the family
it's fantastic Champions League I mean
you know
but if they don't want they continue I
don't mind you know but let them go play
by themselves
if the Court ruling said actually it was
a European Monopoly if the Court ruling
said it was a UEFA Monopoly running the
Champions League UEFA might not be able
to run the Champions League anymore does
that mean you as the clubs would have to
get together and form a new entity to
run today we have the joint venture with
UEFA so it's not UEFA
you know so we have you know shows and
percentage in the John Venture so we're
doing together with UEFA they are the
regular body of course but we're doing
it with them today so
I do understand that saying Monopoly and
it's just
their kind of uh you know lobbying and
their PR and which it's the most stupid
PR I saw in my life honestly because
obviously there are more games in the
Champions League from 2024 there are
eight games per team in the group stage
it's a lovely games but there's there's
a lot of games for sure but that's also
what we want to achieve also to play
more matches high level you built my
Lofts experience now in sport you've
been running Paris Saint-Germain you're
now head of the European Club
association to have bigger Ambitions
maybe to be
UEFA or FIFA president one day
not at all trust me even by the way even
this year I promise you
I was not willing to do it even you know
I've been refusing it as you know but
I'm very proud to be as a chairman
definitely not to have all amazing clubs
you know together and bring them United
that's that was fantastic role but I
don't have any ambition there at all
it's Europe